hi there Steve here with my link t-shirt
and I am all excited because I'm on my
way to Montreal for the North American
polyglot symposium again I prefer to
call it the language festival the
festival day long and I'm quite excited
I've had interviews now with the
Montreal Gazette with virgin olive oil
they phoned me here language learning
for really and I'm going to be on CBC
English and how do Canada in French but
most of all and I'm they're interested I
mean they did what they're most
interested in is why would anyone learn
so many languages and how do people
learn languages and these are subjects
that I love to talk about why people
should learn languages because it's good
for you can basically stride from one
culture to the next and Montreal is a
city that I love and I'm always
impressed by the level of bilingualism
there you never know if it's an
Anglophone speaking French or a
francophone speaking English or so it
seems in downtown Montreal and I'm gonna
meet a lot of these wonderful polyglots
that I have met before but I also want
to meet ordinary people who are
interested in language learning who
don't necessarily have a channel at
youtube so i am all excited i get up
early tomorrow morning i mean i've been
training myself to get up but like at
five in the morning because i arrived in
montreal then we have a dinner and then
at seven the next morning i have a TV
date interview whatever and the core 7
the mornings going to be four in the
morning for me based on vancouver time
so trying to adjust my body clock a
little bit but i'm excited and any of
you who haven't yet signed up and if
you're in the area by all means come out
I will look forward to seeing you there
and that's about it a bientot Mesa me
for Absalom Oh vernia Oh festival day
long polyglot symposium nahuatl come ova
series vasanti I say Oh long nap walk
along van a honk otay
daughter enthusiasts day long a bientot
bye for now